[Musique]
c'était le troisième héros de la célèbre
mission apollo 11
l'astronaute méconnu celui qui est resté
en orbite aux commandes du module de
service pendant que ses deux compagnons
buzz aldrin et neil amstrong 100 km sous
lui poser pour la postérité sur la lune
est décédé d'un cancer à l'âge de 90 ans
celui que la nasa qualifie de véritables
pionniers de l'ère spatiale a d'abord
été pilote d'essais dans l'armée
américaine engagée par la nasa en pleine
guerre froide
il a aussi participé à l'émission jiminy
10 qui a servi de tremplin pour la
conquête de la lune d'une nature plus
discrète qu'elle n'aimait guère le staff
thème autour des astronautes américains
mais il a toujours soutenu activement la
nasa et l'importance de l'exploration
spatiale même espérer qu'un humain
parviennent un jour à se rendre sur mars
et plus loin encore un rêve qui
aujourd'hui sans presque possible
[Musique]
radio canada
montréal